hi I'm Erik Bosse and birds-of-prey the
upcoming DC spin-off movie with Margot
Robbie returning as Harley Quinn from
Suicide Squad has a new teaser that
gives us a look at all the characters
really quick looks with that whole
flashy duplicate montage editing style
that makes our breakdowns really really
fun so I'm gonna break down this footage
frame by freaking frame for all the
details that you might have missed and
explained what this movie is and why you
should be excited for it spoiler warning
the case that revealed too much and ruin
your life let's look at the first part
of this teaser
okay so birds of prey with the extended
bonkers title of the fantabulous
emancipation of one harley quinn hmm
will be a standalone DC story with
Harley Quinn Margot Robbie separated
from the Joker a partner from Suicide
Squad now leading a team of anti heroes
including Black Canary Huntress and
Renee Montoya to save a young girl
Cassandra Kane from an evil crime lord
black mask more on those other
characters in a sec but what we're
looking at here is less of a traditional
teaser or trailer with real film footage
that it is a stylized screen test the
filmmakers a marketing team appeared to
be doing something similar to the screen
tests that was released from the Joaquin
Phoenix Joker movie a few months ago
which is also more of a DC standalone
movie so neither of these teasers are
scenes from their movies they're the
actors in costume and in character on a
film soundstage simply for the
filmmakers to see how they look on
camera which is standard for every big
movie to do but these are released to
the public they have music creative
lighting choices editing so I think this
is designed to give us a bigger sense of
this movie's tone this tone is pony's
birds of braids director is Kathy Yin
and it looks like she's going for a pop
Sofia Coppola aesthetic or something
like the music video of Robyn's call
your girlfriend or taran killam some
amazing recreation of it by the way the
music we're hearing here is called a new
error by moderate let's talk about these
characters the first shot shows Harley
Quinn dangling her signature mallet
which you know we only saw briefly in
Suicide Squad
I remember her using that baseball bat a
lot more than the mallet and then we cut
to another weapon the crossbow
carried by Huntress aka Helena
Bertinelli Huntress was one of the main
birds of prey in the WB series in the
early 2000s but
this movie she's a former mafia princess
whose family was killed in a mob hit
turning her into a vigilante she's
played by Mary Elizabeth Winstead from
Scott Pilgrim vs. world and 10
Cloverfield Lane then we see this bottle
of booze being shoved by Renee Montoya a
detective in the Gotham City police very
cool character she's being played here
by Rosie Perez and then we see this arm
cast this belongs to Cassandra Cain here
she's a young woman - played by Ellijay
Bosco now cast is a much bigger
storyline in the DC Comics she's one of
the bad girls and she currently goes by
the name orphan but in this movie she's
a younger character who's taken in with
black masks criminal enterprise maybe
she was kidnapped
maybe she chose to be part of this gang
or maybe it's a bit of both the lines
can be confusing in a gang I'm speaking
from personal experience obviously yeah
others but look closely at that caps the
doodles include quite a bit of profanity
I'm assuming birds of prey will be
r-rated but also some emblems from the
birds of prey themselves a gun firing a
bullet an arrow Gotham is my city it's
like the older women all made their own
marks on it actually notice those Queen
playing cards from each of the four
suits perhaps corresponding to each of
the four Queens of the birds of prey
like perhaps paid-for Huntress that
arrows pointed in kind of corresponds to
the spades pointed in maybe Club for
Renee Montoya for her police Billie Club
thing diamond for Black Canary kind of
with a luxurious singer version that
they're going with in this movie and the
Queen of Hearts I'm guessing would be
Harley Quinn you know she's got that
whole romantic relationship with the
Joker and before we move on there's a
quick shot of someone with a baseball
bat I'm assuming Harley Quinn this is
just a very different bat and the one
that we saw in Suicide Squad let me know
if you can make out what of any of those
scribbles say boo let's move on to the
second half
[Music]
okay so these rapidfire shots give us a
better look at all the characters if you
don't blink Black Canary is Deena Lance
a young street fighter from the DC
Comics she's often appeared alongside
Green Arrow in the comics animated
series in the CW series black Canary's
known for her ability to emit this
powerful sonic blast called the canary
cry in this movie she's being played by
jurnee smollett bell it appears to be a
kind of lounge singer character notice
how they dyed her hair blonde just like
black Canary's hair has historically
been we also get better looks at
Huntress and Renee Montoya as well as
the villain of this movie black mask
hello there you and McGregor now he's
not wearing his mask obviously here but
black mask is a recurring Batman villain
the alter ego of Roman seal this he grew
up as a wealthy heir obsessed with masks
later running a gang called the false
face society and wearing an ebony skull
mask carved from his father's coffin
yeah a real charmer at one point after a
run-in with Batman that mask actually
got seared onto his face permanently
when he was struck by lightning but
again no awesome mask here look it's
still early in production as a screen
test they want to know what you and
McGregor looks like there's plenty of
other chances for a film production just
look at a mask it's also possible that
this movie could be an origin story and
we're looking at the Roman before shot
or you know maybe this version of black
mask will be one who can take off the
mask kind of like the new 52 iteration
Jeremiah Arkham who worships this mask
in kind of a split personality mania you
know a real charmer
there's also another villain in this
section Victor Zsasz played by Chris
Messina doesn't look anything like
himself zas is from the relatively more
recent comics he's a sadistic serial
killer who carves a tally mark into his
skin for each of his victims how hard to
see a new talent marks on this sash
though zas has shown up in the Gotham
series and he made a cameo and Chris
Nolan's Batman Begins and finally we end
on Harley Quinn spinning in this crazy
pom-pom sleeve jacket if you look
closely you can kind of see what looks
like some shredded police caution tape
in there if so I love it
well so check out her drink this is the
same kind of cocktail and the same exact
kind of glass as the one that she drank
in the bar scene in Suicide Squad it's
like she's been partying ever since that
moment but the most interesting part of
her outfit is among the charms around
her neck one of them is a dog tag not a
military dog tag this one is in the
shape of a dog bone and it says the name
Bruce you know this could be a pretty
big
deal because this would imply Harley
knows Batman's secret identity is Bruce
Wayne something that hasn't really been
confirmed before like in the animated
movie return of the Joker we find out
that the Joker did learn Batman's
identity after torturing Tim Drake and
in the live-action DC EU Zack Snyder
confirmed that the Robin suit Easter egg
a Batman V Superman did mean that the
Joker did murder Dick Grayson in the
past so maybe something similar has
happened in the live-action continuity
and that's how the Joker would have
found out and maybe he would have told
Harley Quinn but ultimately I think this
Bruce tag is just more of a wink
reference than an actual implication for
any plot events that we should be
looking for in birds of prey either that
Batman will make a cameo or that Harley
Quinn will know that Batman is Bruce
Wayne really I think it's more likely
this could be a reference to Bruce Timm
the co-creator of the Harley Quinn
character in the Batman the Animated
Series as we wait for this movie to come
out on February 7 2020 over a year from
now and remember this is just a first
look a screen test we don't really know
what this movie its tone is going to be
until the trailer comes out so do you
think birds of prey should embrace the
colourful neon pop music tone from
Suicide Squad or explore the darker
aesthetic of DCU movies like Batman V
Superman comment down below follow us
and subscribe to this channel and
subscribe to our new podcast wherever
you listen to podcasts and if you live
in the LA area
come see my live comedy show darkest
timeline comedy starring the e with
appearances by Philip Mon and Tommy from
new rock stars and some other hilarious
comedians that I know from LA and so
many a nerdy bits this Friday February
1st at Acme comedy in North Hollywood
thanks for watching and I know you sad
the videos over but don't worry
[Music]